erupting with fury
beirut is a city tearing itself apart
these protests are the biggest and most
violent in months
with young and old gripped by anger at
the authorities
it is a sign of how the explosion which
devastated more than half the capital
has galvanized a desperate population
already at breaking point from deepening
economic
and political crises that our government
did not deploy
one soldier or one policeman to help us
to remove the bodies from under the
rubble
did not help us for five days not remove
one
old woman from any building any any
stone and here they are
makeshift gallows were constructed in
martyrs square
many here want to metaphorically hang
the ruling elite
and remove them from power others want
them to literally
swing we're gonna kill them we wanna
kill them
we want they destroyed our beirut this
is ours
as the gas choked through the city a
burning sense of righteous anger brought
more and more people onto the streets
determined to reach the parliament
building
a symbol of the rottenness at the heart
of this country
they're shouting which means revolution
that beirut hadn't experienced enough
trauma
the city is convulsing with anger
people are furious with their
governments and with the authorities
most of the people here their apartments
their homes have been destroyed
and they want justice make no mistake
this is a dangerous moment for the
country
plastic bullets crackled through the air
some of the protesters were seriously
injured
with blood once again spilling onto
beirut's tired streets
[Applause]
and already battered people facing the
full force
of state security
[Applause]
how this ends is not yet clear but what
is certain is that no one will accept to
return to the status quo
in response the prime minister hassan
diab made an unscheduled and brief tv
appearance
calling for early elections
but it's a move that's unlikely to
defuse the anger here
these people want reform of the entire
system
by early evening the protesters had
taken over the foreign ministry
occupying one of the government seats of
power
the revolutionary fervor soon spilled
into the main banking institution
where officers were torched and
equipment was smashed
the blame protesters say for this
hellish descent into chaos
lies only with a ruling class who are
accused of plundering the nation's
resources
protests are planned for the coming days
but for now this
is a city in pain that doesn't know
how to heal its wounds